nous avons commencé à recevoir des visiteurs de
tous les univers bonjour peter c'était
très agréable de revenir à quelque chose qui
est familier mais en même temps
complètement nouveau tu n'es pas peter parker je
suis tellement confus en ce moment 20 ans depuis
son gobelin vert
dix-sept ans depuis  ma première fois en tant que
doc quel était ton nom encore dr otto
octavius
sérieusement quel est ton vrai nom tu as
une autre chance de remuer certaines choses
comment tu aimes la nouvelle nouvelle électro c'est comme si
le monde m'avait fait du tort maintenant j'ai cette
énergie je suis sur le point  pour aller chercher le mien tu
ne vas pas m'enlever ça
darkhawk reprend là où il s'est arrêté
qu'as-tu fait de ma machine il
cherche à se venger veux-tu jouer à des
jeux
le gobelin croit en un monde de perdants
et de gagnants le pouvoir est  tout ce qui compte
[Musique]
c'est un monde merveilleux dans lequel nous
nous amusons beaucoup ils sont un danger pour
notre univers nous devons les renvoyer on
dirait que nous avons de la concurrence
je pense que les gens vont être vraiment
surpris ils '  concernant  va s'émerveiller
[Musique] d'
accord parker tu es prêt
[Musique]
fais-le
exclusivement dans les cinémas
nous
trafiquons le tissu de la réalité
ce qui se passe commence à
arriver et je ne peux pas l'arrêter
je ne peux pas croire que je suis dans les saints je
Je dis que c'est horum
et je
ne peux pas non plus connaître un peter parker qui est
spider-man oui c'est lui non
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît expliquer ce qui se passe
après que j'ai fermé ce sort nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de chaque univers
multivers est réel
j'ai besoin de toi  pour les capturer avant qu'ils ne
détruisent le tissu de la réalité, je vais
avoir besoin d'aide, les gars, prêts
attrapons des hommes multivers
spider-man pas de retour à la maison quel était votre
nom encore dr otto octavius
sérieusement quel est votre vrai nom
vous